hey what's up ladies and gentlemen
some of you may remember when I made one
of my first Oreo stork videos I told you
that I would make another oriya video
and give you my season a prediction for
her faith so in this video that's
exactly what I'm gonna do I'm gonna try
to keep this video very short and simple
when I was talking a gray area in
secrets of the Citadel last week we
briefly discuss this topic we have plans
on making a season seven predictions
video about Oriya historical and gray
areas channel and during that
conversation secrets of the Citadel and
I both agreed that we think Arya Stark
will die in the very end of the story
gray area actually disagreed and she's
probably going to kill me for saying
this again but I'm very curious to see
what all of you have to say about this
so I had to make a video about it and
give my opinion as well but let me
preface this by saying I hope I am wrong
I do not want Arya to die but the
foreshadowing in the very first novel a
game of Thrones cannot be dismissed I
think most people believe Arya Stark
will survive the entire series our story
simply because Arya is George RR
Martin's wife's favorite character since
Oriya is her favorite character people
say that there is no way george RR
martin would kill Arya Stark because of
that but I don't think that is
necessarily true no character is safe in
this story and given that this is
ultimately an anti-war story most of if
not all of the beloved characters very
well could die in the end I don't think
all of them are going to die but it is
possible another reason why most people
believe Arya Stark will survive is
because of George RR Martin's original
draft that he wrote back in 1993 if you
have not read George RR Martin's
original draft for a Song of Ice and
Fire
you can watch that video I made about it
and which I read his entire draft and
give my opinion on it I will put that
link down in the description but in that
original draft George planned on having
five characters survive the entire story
one of those characters was Arya Stark
now I will admit if this draft is really
his that he wrote then that is some very
good evidence pointing towards Arya
survival but a lot has changed since
then in fact several different plots and
this draft have
changed he originally only wanted to
write three books which now has turned
into seven and he also originally wanted
Arya Stark to be in sort of a love
triangle between John and Tyrion
obviously that has changed and I think
her fate may have changed as well in the
very first season of Game of Thrones you
can see just how much Arya reminds Ned
of his sister Lyanna
while Arya is training with Syrio the
camera pans to Ned's face and he looks
very troubled in this moment it's
obvious that this is reminding Ned of
something from the past this scene can
be interpreted in many ways one way to
interpret this scene is that Oriya is
reminding Ned of his sister Lyanna and
to go even further than that this may
even be reminding Ned of the tower of
joy if you look at the way Arya is
training the way she gets stabbed by
Serio is identical to the way Arthur
Dayne stabbed one of Ned's men so
perhaps this is giving meta flashback to
the day he tried to save his sister but
like most things in this story in series
this scene could also have a double
meaning to it this could also be
foreshadowing Orias death
Arya may be killed exactly the same way
Serio stabbed her with the wooden sword
that could be another reason why Ned had
that look of shock on his face knowing
that his family was in the midst of some
very dangerous times not only being in
King's Landing surrounded by the enemy
but also because winter is coming
Ned even says to Arya you have a
wildness and you child the wolf's blood
my father used to call it leona had a
touch of it and my brother brandon more
than a touch it brought them both to an
early grave
perhaps Arya may have the same outcome
personally it feels like the path
aurilla is taking won't have a happy
ending for her although I do want a
happy ending for her but the most
foretelling piece of evidence about
aurea's future can be found in one of
the very first chapters in the Game of
Thrones novel this entire story is
shrouded in mystery but clues are left
and things are always foreshadowed way
in advance that tells us exactly how
things are going to end up taking place
when the Lannisters were in Winterfell
Robb and Joffrey were moments away from
exchanging blows and this is when John
tells Arya you had best run back to
little sister septum or dane will surely
be lurking the longer you hide the
sterner the penance
you'll be sowing all for winter when the
spring thaw comes they'll find your body
with the needle still locked tight
between your frozen fingers now I think
that's a very interesting thing John
says to Aria that can have so many
different meanings it sounds to me that
Aria will be found dead not with a
sewing needle locked between her frozen
fingers but her sword needle that John
actually gave to her locked between her
frozen fingers how tragic would it be if
John is actually the one to discover her
body after the snow thaws that would
definitely add some bitterness to a
potential bittersweet ending but it
could also mean something else John says
go back to your room little sister
the longer you hide the sterner the
penance perhaps this can be a reference
to her becoming no.1 in hiding behind
another person's face the longer she is
no-one the more sewing she will be doing
all through winter only sewing with her
sword needle means killing in descending
into the darkness that that path would
lead her to but this could mean that if
she goes back to her room meaning her
home that's where she can be safe when
the snow falls and the white winds blow
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
I think the more Oriya goes down this
dark path the less likely it is for her
to survive
I love seeing her get revenge for her
and her family but there is no way this
ends happily maybe that's why a stark
always needs to be in wonderful that
doesn't just have to mean one stark must
always be in Winterfell but all the
Starks must be there damn near every
time a star please Winterfell they end
up dead Liyana
Ned Catelyn Robb Brandon record benjin
sort of even Rickon wandering to
somewhere he thought was safe ended up
getting him killed even though he
ultimately made it back but I do think
if Arya dies especially in the books I
believe she can warg into Nymeria and
live out the rest of her life in spirit
through Nymeria in the wolf pack but I
wanted to keep this short so let me end
this right here please comment below and
give me your
opinion in prediction for arias endgame
in season 8 how do you see her story
ending I'm curious what the majority of
you think also let me get some shoutouts
to everyone that has helped me in the
channel by coming through big time over
on patreon my computer actually crashed
again so it's getting harder and harder
for me to produce quality videos which
is probably why the audio when this
video sounds kind of shitty right now
but with the donation some of you gave
me on patreon it will help me
tremendously that way I can get a new
one so thank you to feel on defense quad
indie sports car podcast
James Millar gene USMC McCann Ella
golden girl Jeanette cows [ __ ]
chickens Marine Carrie cypher Sir Thomas
solar brain the Builder there on the
drunken Travis McIntyre Thomas Miller
Christopher and daughter of Ice and Fire
you guys are the real MVP s I love you
all see you down in the comment section
bye